INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
And so in today's video,
we're going to continue down
this thread of using Redshift.
Again, as a reminder,
Redshift is a tool,
is a data warehousing tool
that allows us to expand
the capacity of what we can do.
If we're working with a really
data-intensive workflow,
we're working on a
data analytics type
project or some
really big data sets,
then we're probably going to
be leaning towards Redshift
because of all the
reasons we talked about
in the last lecture.
So in the last
lecture, we ended off
with walking through how to
query a table in Redshift.
But that also assumed
that we already
had that table
existing there, which,
if you're coming
into a new company,
it's not unlikely to
have as a situation.
But I want you to also see
how to load in your own data.
And unsurprisingly, one of
the better ways to do that
is just via S3.
I mean, it being such a cheap
storage platform or storage
option, I want you to see how
to pull in data from there.
And so we'll walk through
a demo of how to do that.
And so to start with, we're just
going to go ahead and set up
a Redshift instance.
Now, again, I would
recommend that if you're
doing this along with me, do it
along on your personal account.
Really inconsistent
performance if we're
doing this via your
university account,
so let's just save
all the headache
and just do it that way.
Again, you can do
everything on the free tier.
And even if it's not
on the free tier,
we're only going to
run it for long enough
to just see how it
works and then shut it
back down so it won't charge
anything more than a few cents,
if that even.
And then the other
side of this, too,
is, again, for the
Redshift side of things,
I'm not going to
require you to do this.
This is not going to be a
homework assignment or unit
project that has you deploy
anything via Redshift,
just because, again, it's such a
specific product to a very, very
specific, large use case
that it's not really
practical for you to
do as an individual,
usually, unless you kind of are
already on a project like that,
and at which point, you
probably have a better sense
of the tools you need to use.
So I just want you to be exposed
to it, know that it exists.
Because for those of you that
are interested in these data
analytics type jobs, you
will see this as a tool.
It's very widely used.
So yeah, that's my little
soapbox there for a second.
So I'll shrink myself
out of the way for now,
and then let's jump over
here to the console.
And so we're just going
to do exactly what we
did last time to
create a cluster,
so I'm going to zoom
in a little bit.
So again, if you don't have this
showing up here with Redshift
already, you can just come
up here into the Search bar
and search Redshift.
And then we're not going
to do a serverless.
We're just going to
do the classic way
of creating a cluster.
So let's call our cluster
something meaningful,
so I'll just say
redshift-cluster-sharadjones.
I'm going to run this
on a production one,
just so you can see some of
the other options that we have.
But conceivably, this should
run on the free trial version
as well.
But again, like I said,
I'm going to shut it down
once I'm done with this.
So I'm not super worried
about the cost here.
So if you're on the
production, though, you
see you do have all the choices.
So be very intentional
about what you choose here.
We definitely don't need
to be running with the most
high performance options here.
So you can see both of these or
all of these here on the RA3.
This is $1 per node per hour.
This is $3 per node per
hour, $14 per nodes per hour.
We're going to use
the dc2.large, which
is the same as what we would use
on the free tier anyways, which
is $0.33 per hour,
which you can see
that we do have some other
options as well, too.
So let's just run
with DC2 for now.
And then under a
number of nodes,
we'll leave two nodes for now.
So let's imagine working with
a two-node compute or two
compute nodes.
And so you can
see the rough cost
of what we'd pay for this,
about $470 per month.
So again, these are
not trivial costs
here that you're working with.
So again, if you're not
comfortable or confident
that you won't forget
to delete this,
something like that, you are
more than welcome to not run
this live.
I'm not asking you guys
to do anything that's
going to cost at this scale.
But again, if you want
to it won't be an issue,
because that's per month.
We're going to be
shutting this down
after about 20 to 30 minutes,
depending on how long this
takes you to get through.
If you're doing the free
trial, it automatically
loads the sample data,
though, that ticket data
set that we had last time.
We'll just choose
to load it this time
to ensure that we
have it in case
we want to check and
make sure things are
working when we get connected.
So we'll default, load
the sample data set.
Then you got to put
in a password here.
And again, this is going to be--
let me make sure I type this
correctly as I'm talking,
so let me type first, then talk.
So again, this is going to be
an admin password, so you can
log into it once you have that.
And then you might not see
actually this right here
already.
But if you don't see it
already, or even if you do,
you can come in here
and do Manage IAM roles
and then Create IAM role.
And you see it's
expecting that you
want to create a-- you're
wanting to create a role that
has access to Redshift,
or better, save them
to S3 because S3
is probably where
we're grabbing our data from.
And so you can
choose then if you
want to give access
to No additional S3
buckets, Specific S3
buckets, or Any S3 bucket.
And I'll just do Any S3
bucket for now for simplicity.
But this is, again,
just a quick way
to create a default IAM role
for your Redshift instance.
And also note that you can
only have one default IAM
role for your instance, too.
So you'll see it's going
to create it as a default.
And then now this
one's not apply--
or this one's status is
shown as Not applied,
but the role type
isn't default either.
I don't think we even need
to, technically, associate
this IAM role.
I think we can get away with--
yeah, the default one should
be the one that's already--
or that gets applied to it
anyways when we go live.
Then if you want to
come in here and see
these a few other
things, it's going
to create a default
database called dev.
The database port for
Redshift by default is 5439.
So again, we've been working
with a couple of different ports
in this course, but 5439 is
the reserved port for Redshift.
And everything else you
can just leave the same.
Again, we're not
going to leverage
any of these other
tools, but you
can see plenty of more
options for maintenance,
monitoring, backup, as well
as network and security,
so as far as creating VPCs and
security groups and availability
zones.
So all the usual AWS features
exist for Redshift as well.
So we'll do Create cluster now,
and I don't need to save this.
And then now I'm going to pause
this because as we saw before,
this takes a couple
of minutes to go live.
So I'll pause it and then
come back once mine is live.
All right, so now that
our cluster is live,
we should be able to
go in and query it.
Let me slide this over so I
get a little more sun coverage.
My office here is just
directly in the sunlight
this time of year.
And sorry if I click
through that too quickly.
If you click on your cluster,
again, you click query data.
And I'm just using editor v2.
Then it'll pull up this
window for you, which
is just your query window.
So everything is as expected.
And so remember this is
that query from last time
on the sample data set
that they have in here.
It probably isn't even
running from the right table.
You're running in
the right cluster.
Let's see.
Here we go.
So now it's set to run, so
let's see if it'll run now.
There we go.
Yeah, so that was, again,
just our sample query,
and this is running from this--
I can't remember if they
put it in this location,
or if they put it in-- yeah, so
it's all in here under this dev.
And the sample data dev
here is just another folder,
but this dev database is
where all of the sample data
was loaded.
And so now we want
to see, again,
how to create or upload a new
data set, and specifically
from S3.
So this is going to be, again,
something you guys will probably
appreciate.
It's very easy to do this.
It's not like we've
done before where
we had to go into a bunch
of different things,
but we will see a kind of
slightly more complicated way
to do this.
So the way we do
this, though, is
to come in here to Create
and then Create a table,
unsurprisingly.
And then what I want
to do is I first
want to load the column
names from a data set.
So this saves me a
little bit of hassle
of having to type in what all my
column names are, and also saves
it from not having to infer what
the column names are later on.
So I'm going to actually just
browse my local directory
for this, and I have this file.
It should be on Canvas
as well, double-check.
Let me see here.
Where did I put this file?
Might actually be in
one of my other courses.
Let's go here.
I'll make sure it's
on Canvas, though.
So this mhealth_raw_data.csv
is the one I'm going to use.
So you can see this is
decently large data set,
and let me actually go
make sure it's on Canvas as
well while we're at it.
Actually, I'll do it
after this lecture.
But either way, it'll
be up there for you all.
And so this is all
the column names,
and you can see here
that it's loaded them
in as all decimal values
here, except for the subject
name, which is a variable
size character and then
an integer for activity.
And so it's a data set on here.
I'll load it up, too, so
you can see it on here.
It's a Mobile Health
Human Behavior Analysis,
so that's what the
MHEALTH stands for.
It's 3 sensor devices, 10
subjects, 12 activities.
But it's a decent size, too.
I forget exactly how many
rows are in this data sets,
so let me see.
And we'll see in a second here,
but it's a decently large data
set, so something
that we probably
would want to use a
tool like this for.
So it looks like we might have
around a million or so rows
in it, but we'll
confirm in a second.
So either way, we're going to
create this table from that.
And we'll just name it mhealth.
OK.
Actually, I think this might
be loading it from a local--
oh, Schema.
Here, public.
There we go.
Create table.
All right, so the
table is created now,
but there's not anything
in it, if I'm not mistaken.
I shouldn't have loaded
anything in there yet.
And so we can see, if we do just
select everything from that,
is it loading anything yet?
Yeah, perfect.
So No Rows To Show.
So it just loaded
the column names.
So now we actually need to go
in and load the data up from S3
or load the data
from S3 into this.
So let's see here.
If we go--
I think we can right now.
Let's see.
Oh, there we go, Load data,
obviously, right next to it.
So let's go Load data.
And now we can do
Browse S3, and it's
going to browse our
local S3 bucket.
So if you're doing this,
again, not on our account
or on your university
account, which,
again, I don't recommend
doing it on here.
If you're doing it on
your personal account,
you'll need to upload this file
to S3 for you to access it.
And you can just
click on the bucket,
and then you'll see
it's already on this--
you're in this S3 bucket here,
this mhealth_raw_data.csv.
So we'll just check
that, and click Choose.
It looks like I actually
created this in us-west-1.
Or actually, let me just
double-check over here.
It needs to know
the region of our--
yeah, so I'm in
us-west-1 right now,
so I'm going to make
sure I load it there.
It's a CSV.
And then I think we need to go--
is there an advanced?
Here we go, Advanced Settings,
under Load operations,
I believe--
or is it back--
let's see.
There we go.
Yeah, so under the data
conversion parameters,
I just want to say,
Ignore header rows
because the first
row of this data set
is the names of the headers.
You can see the column
names here, arx, ary.
I don't want to load those in.
I want to keep those from--
they're already preloaded.
And I just want to load over--
or fill in those values
correctly in here.
So we'll do Done there.
And then the Schema is going to
go in that same public schema,
and then the data
or the table is
going to be the mhealth table
that we already created.
We already have
the column mapping.
I don't think we'll need an--
actually, yeah, let's assign
our IAM role, just in case.
And let's do Load data.
Oh, S3 bucket
addressed by the query
is in a different region
from this cluster.
Oh, and this is where I've made
my mistake number one here.
So I didn't create my
cluster in this region.
So what I'm actually
going to do,
rather than just doing this
without showing you guys,
I'm going to come back in here.
And I'm going to load this file
into S3 in this specific region.
I think that might
be my issue here.
So again, the error says ERROR--
S3ServiceException-- S3
bucket addressed by the query
is in a different region
from this cluster.
So come in here.
Should be a global location.
That's the part
that's confusing me.
Maybe I'll pause it here.
That way, you don't have to
just watch me stare at this.
And then I'll come
back once I figured out
how to solve the problem.
All right, it was
actually a simple fix.
So the only thing I
did different here
was, so when I came
in and specified this,
I had just specified
us-west-1 and where
my cluster was located.
But all I needed to
specify was us-west-2,
which is where I must
have uploaded it from.
Either way, solved that problem.
So us-west-2, data
conversion parameters.
Ignore header rows,
and then go ahead
and select your access
role, your IAM role,
and then just click Load data.
And it'll take about
10, 20 seconds.
It's not very long
at all to load it in.
It'll run this command
basically, so copying--
so what that, really,
the wizard helps
us do is avoid having to
write our query ourselves.
So it's just saying COPY
this from this location
with this role,
format as a CSV file.
Ignore the one header
row, and the region
is set to us-west-2,
so solves that problem.
So yeah, once you
have that, then you
can just query your table here.
So I'm just checking
the first hundred rows.
You can see here, this is
just the first hundred rows
of this data set.
We have subject name, the
activity that they were doing.
And the reason it
looks like repeats
is because it's a time series.
So there's a bunch of times.
You can see some of
these values change,
so it's the sensor reading
over time for a specific user.
We can try other commands
or other queries,
so here's another one
I had written up here.
So what was I looking
at with this one.
So we do-- oh, I removed
the numbers, too.
This is just coming
out of the notes.
So if you want to copy
and paste from there,
you're more than welcome to.
So SELECT average aly value,
which forget what aly was.
It was the-- let's
just pull it up again.
Aly is the acceleration
from the left ankle
sensor for this specific
mobile health data set.
So the acceleration
from this sensor,
I'm getting the average value
of that from our data set,
where we have subject1
AND activity = 9.
So for a specific activity,
for a specific subject,
what's the average
sensor reading here?
Dev public.
Oh, I guess we call the data
set something different here.
So let's try that again.
And we'll wait for the query
to run, and there we go.
And so we're able to
take the average, again,
of a very large data set.
So we can probably even
see some properties here.
Do they have a--
or let's just select--
let me see here.
What can we do to see this?
So let's select-- my
SQL skills are very bad.
Let's see.
SELECT COUNT of aly from
this, and let's just
select all the rows.
Yep, so we have
1.2 million rows.
So we were able to average
that relatively quickly.
So it's not bad at all.
And again, this is just
doing something simple,
like averaging.
We're really not going to
see the power of Redshift
until we're doing
something that's
well beyond what we could
do in something like RDS
or anything like that.
Another thing I wanted to
show, too, really quick
is if we had run this query here
where we're getting the average
or something like
that, we can also
look at some charts
related to it.
So if we click Charts here, let
me see, click the Chart button
below--
oh, sorry, I want it
to go underneath here.
I can't really see
my whole screen
because I'm using this
window here for a second.
Let's see, so
Chart button below.
Where is my chart button?
There we go.
It's this tiny,
little toggle button.
But you can see here, it's a
nice little, quick BI tool.
So we can-- let's just
return everything for now.
Let's do SELECT
everything from here.
Let's run this really quick.
And we can choose aly.
Or let's say maybe we choose--
let's do activity on
the horizontal axis.
Oops.
Let's go activity on
the horizontal axis,
and let's go the
acceleration on the y-axis.
And here we go.
Let's change the type.
We can change the style
here where are we at.
Line scatterplot.
Let me increase the size
so I can actually see this.
I should have probably
prepped a good visualization,
because I haven't actually
tried one of these yet.
Let me pause real
quick and see if I
can come up with a good
chart for you to see.
All right, so here we go.
I've switched it to be something
a little bit more interesting.
So I just filtered on subject1
and one specific activity.
And so now I'm
looking at the ankle--
yeah, the acceleration of the
left ankle sensor and the y-axis
and the right ankle sensor on
the y-- or yeah, the left ankle
sensor on the y-axis and the
right ankle sensor on the x-axis
here.
So you can see here, you can
create these scatter plots.
And so that's really
just to say again
that, hey, there are other
things you can do with this.
And you can leverage
all these tools
to build charts right
in here and start
to analyze your data directly.
Again, not critical that
we know how to do all this.
This is a separate
class altogether.
This is visualizations, but
not doing visualizations here.
I do want to show you
one more thing, though,
because, again, we talked
about this a little bit
in the last lecture,
in that there
are specific functions,
specific queries for Redshift
because certain things can be
parallelized in different ways.
So this link here,
this SQL functions,
gives you a sense of the
types of SQL functions
that you can do in
Redshift or basically
natively designed here.
These will be the
most efficient.
These will be the most efficient
at leveraging all parallelizable
capabilities of Redshift.
And so, for example,
I can click in here,
and there's even
things like machine
learning functions, such
as explaining models
or how to explain
the models that we
might be fitting in our
machine learning queries.
And so it really
opens up the capacity
quite a bit of what
you can do in SQL.
But also, you need to be very
clear in trying to leverage
these as much as
possible to make sure
everything is running as
efficiently as possible.
So you can see all of
your built-in functions
for math and whatnot, so that's
just there as a reference.
Again, not critical we
get into this right now.
The next thing I did
want to look at, though,
was, first off,
what it would take--
or a better
statement, how can we
query to and from
this Redshift instance
if we're on a-- or in working in
Python or something like that?
So to do that, I'm going
to set up an EC2 instance.
And also, I need to make
sure that my Redshift
cluster is publicly available.
So to first do that, if I
come back to my cluster,
go under Actions.
And I'll go Modify publicly
accessible setting.
Very simply, I can
just check this box,
and it turns on the
publicly accessible setting.
So now any client can connect
to it from outside the VPC.
Now granted, you'll still
need the login information
and whatnot.
But assuming you have
that, be good to go.
And we're not going to assign
an elastic IP to this cluster,
because we don't have
an elastic IP setup.
But that would be, for
example, if you have this
and you want it to be
permanent, whether you shut down
the cluster and
start it back up,
you want to make sure the
IP address stays the same
so you don't have
to keep changing
your code that's running.
Then you'd set up an elastic IP.
So let's do Save Changes there.
And while that's running,
let's launch an EC2 instance.
So I'll come over here to EC2.
Let's do Launch an instance.
And again, we're doing
nothing fancy here.
Let's call it SharadRedshift.
And I'm going to do
all this the same
as we've been doing this
whole semester, so nothing
fancy, 20.04, t2.micro.
I have my key pair.
Actually, I don't know if I
have a key pair on the-- let's
see us-west-2
because I don't have
a key pair on the us-west-1.
Let's go back to
us-west-2 really quick,
shouldn't matter at
all because we're using
a publicly available instance
or publicly available cluster.
So we'll do SharadRedshift,
Ubuntu 20.04, t2.micro.
I'll use my demo key pair here.
Select existing security
group, which is 3600sg.
And let's just make sure we can
access S3 in case we want to--
there you go.
So we'll launch
instance, and let
me get my terminal
window prepared here
while that's connecting.
We'll come back to this.
Refresh.
And we're just waiting for this
to enter a connecting state
so we can connect to it.
Check one more time.
And as you know, this
usually takes a second here.
So feel free to skip
ahead about 3 seconds.
But I imagine, by the time I
shut this down and reconnect,
it'll already be ready to go.
And there we go.
So Connect, SSH client.
I'm going to copy this.
Pull up my terminal.
Connect.
So I need to make sure I'm
in my Downloads folder.
Now it doesn't want
to let me do this.
Nope.
Port 22 connection refused.
What did I change?
This is actually a
good learning lesson.
Let's make sure that our
ports are all set up.
So demo key pair is good.
Port 22 is open.
The only other thing
that could be going on
is if I don't actually
have that key pair in this.
I think I see that in
there on my demo key pair.
Let's try one more time before
I just reboot this altogether.
Here we go.
For whatever reason,
sometimes it has that.
you know how it goes.
So let's do our sudo
apt update really quick.
And then I'm going to need to
install a Redshift connector,
so I to actually
first install pip.
So I'm going to go back to my--
I think it's lecture
12 notes maybe.
Yeah, here we go.
So go through our lecture 12
notes here to just install pip.
Let's curl that.
Python3.
Let's do this one.
And so now we should
be able to do pip3
install redshift_connector.
And this is how we're going to
set up our Redshift connection.
And so while that's
installing, let's
go back to our security
group over here.
And I'm actually going
to add a rule here.
So actually, we might need
to do it under the cluster.
Let me see if it's in
the cluster or in this.
So if we go to cluster
really quick, under--
let me see.
Oh, it's being
modified right now.
So it might not let me
edit the security group.
Yep.
So I'll pause it
and wait because we
need to let this finish
the modifying state,
so then I can
actually go in here
and update the security group.
All right, so now that
it is available again
after-- again,
that was just-- it
was waiting for it to modify
the publicly accessible setting.
What we need to ensure is
that our port was the 5439,
I believe, is open so that
we can query into that.
That's that default
Redshift port.
And so if I come
under Properties
and this is in my cluster, I'll
see my security group here,
my VPC security group.
So let's click into there and
then go our Inbound rules,
edit Inbound rules.
And then we'll do Add Rule.
And thankfully, there is
a default Redshift one.
It does have 5439.
And so we should
be able to change
that to be there for everywhere,
and just save that rule.
So conceivably, that
should open it up for us.
Now, if we go back
to our terminal,
we'll create a new file.
We'll just call it
redshiftdemo.py.
And I'm just going to copy
and paste this code from here
while we talk about it.
Let's go Insert, Paste.
And so all we're
going to do is import
the Redshift connector
package or library.
We're going to create
this connection,
and we'll need to
obviously change our host
to be the relevant host.
The database, the user,
the password, all of that's
going to be changed.
And then from there,
we're going to connect.
We're going do this,
connect to cursor.
And then we're going to execute
this query, which that's just
querying from that sales table.
So we'll just use that one.
It's fine.
And so I'm going to drag
the terminal out of the way
now so I can add my
password privately.
Or actually, first I'll do the
host name so you can see that.
So let's go to Redshift again.
And our host name is this
endpoint right here, I believe.
So let's copy and
paste that endpoint.
Let's go up here, to
the end of our sentence.
Oops.
[BEEP]
Making too many changes
here, so let's go back here.
We're just going to
delete all of this
and then paste in our
endpoint for that.
The database is
still dev, though.
Though, I might
actually remove it here.
I can't remember if I need to
remove it around, so we'll see.
If it doesn't work,
then we'll add it back.
We'll add the dev back in there,
but dev should be the same.
User-- we'll change that.
And then password-- I'm going
to go and type in my password
and then end it with a
quotation mark, like that.
And then I'm going
to Save and Exit.
So add the password
in really quick.
All right, so should
be good to go in there,
and so now let's
see if this works.
I'm assuming it won't.
We always got to try some things
out or run through some errors.
Let's try it.
So redshiftdemo.pi.
Here we go.
So good.
So what do we got here?
So we have a
communication error.
Name or service not known.
OK, great, so maybe that
is the issue with the devs.
Let's try changing
the dev really quick.
So here I'll just
show you, or let
me remove my password
really quick again so you
don't have to see my password.
And then I'm just going
to come back in here
and add dev to the
tail end of that.
If not, not super stressed
if this part doesn't work.
But I just want to be sure
that we try everything.
All right, then I'm
going to add my password
back in really quick.
Sorry.
This is the least
convenient way.
I'm sure there's
probably a better way
to hide my password
as I'm doing this.
And save that.
Let's try it one more time.
OK, then I'm going to pause
and try to solve it again.
You know how this goes.
I'll come back and
tell you how I fix it.
As always, it's
something simple.
But I can't code live.
There's no way I'll
ever solve that problem.
But either way, the issue is
just that I need to just remove
this /dev and the 5439
because it already knows to go
for a Redshift query
to look into port 5439.
So it was trying
to do 5439 twice,
and that's where I was throwing
that error of not being
able to find the connection.
But dev, awsuser is the same.
Let me add my password
back in here, then save,
and then I'll show you.
So add the password, escape
colon WQ to save and exit.
And then now here, let's
clear this out for a second.
If we do python3
redshiftdemo.py,
and you can see that
we have successfully
now queried our database.
So we've queried
the sales database
and returned this information.
So that's really all I wanted
to show you with regard to that.
Again, all this tells
us now is that using
this syntax of our
querying or better
statement of this function,
we can query a Redshift
database and,
really, anything else
that we did before connected
to an API or building an API,
running something in Python
and then just grabbing
the data from Redshift.
All of that stuff
is open to us now.
You can use this logic to do
anything else that we've talked
about before in this course.
And so that connects
all the pieces there,
gives us RDS as a tool,
gives us Redshift as a tool.
And so from here
now, we're going
to pivot more towards the
analytics and machine learning
side of things.
But I still want you to keep
in mind this side of it.
This is how we're going to store
and aggregate our data always.
It's just now a matter of
what to do with that data.
So with that, I'll
leave you there.
Plenty to look through.
Again, by no means am I going
to expect you guys to do this.
It's too much risk for
very expensive costs.
So don't worry about running
this live if you didn't do it.
If you did do it, make
sure you delete it now.
And I'll run through those
steps actually to insure it.
So first, let me exit out of
my terminal here for a second,
and then I'll start with just
deleting my Redshift cluster.
So I'm going to do Delete.
I don't need a final snapshot.
We'll just delete that
cluster that's being deleted.
Then I'll come back over
to my EC2 instance as well.
I'll terminate that instance.
And so that should remove
any possibility of cost.
So at most, I probably got
charged about $0.60 for that
hour-ish of working on
this, so not terrible,
but not something you want to
leave live for any bit of time.
Nor do I want you all to
try to do this either.
So hopefully, that was
some bit informative.
Again, keep this in
the back of your mind
if you ever find
yourself starting
to work on a big data problem.
Or in a class down the line,
maybe in a master's program
or something like that where
you need to leverage that,
you have this tool now.
It's there, ready to use.
Really simple to
use, as you can see.
It's just a matter of
spinning up the cluster,
and you can query it right there
or connect to it pretty simply.
So I'll leave it at that.
And again, we'll talk next time
on some more machine learning
and analytics type things.
So Thanks for watching.
Bye